[Music]
the writer strike is finally over season
two of House of the Dragon will be
coming out next summer with some new
celebrity editions and Netflix May soon
not be available in 4k anymore more info
on sakario 3 with Bono Del Toro Paw
Patrol 3 and more is now available on
this week's Koch
news Paw Patrol 2 The Mighty movie has
not even started yet already the big
announcement Paw Patrol 3 is coming was
made
Paramount Pictures has given the green
light for the sequel which is scheduled
to hit theaters in 2026 the feature
films are based on the globally
successful children's series developed
by spinmaster entertainment it has
existed since 2013 and is currently in
its 10th season originally broadcasted
on Canadian Channel TV Ontario the
series found its way to film distributor
Paramount pictures via Nickelodeon Paw
Patrol the movie took in $144 million
worldwide in 2021 direction for the
Third film is in the hands of Cal
brunker who previously directed the
first two films The Producers include
numerous names who are also responsible
for the Animated Series while the
announcement of Paw Patrol 3 is making
the rounds however the public is
probably looking forward to the
theatrical release of Paw Patrol the
mighty movie on September 29th another
box office success for the worldwide
phenomenon seems more than
likely 5 years after sakario 2 day of
Sado the producers of the series have
given the green light for another sequel
in which bicho Del Toro will once again
take on the role of the mysterious
assassin Alejandro with the film sakario
released in 2015 Dune director Dennis
venev created one of the most popular
and Grim Thrillers of the last decade
however the sequel fell short of
expectations and a third part seemed far
away at that time in an interview with
the messenger the producers of the
series surprisingly announced that a
third part was still being considered
and that great ideas were already on the
table in addition we can also look
forward to a return of bonio Del Toro
who is going to play the role of the
merciless assassin Alejandro gillick
again producer basil iwanik said I can't
wait for sakario 3 I could watch Bono
play that guy forever I mean I can watch
Bono in anything but in that character
it doesn't get old whether we can also
look forward to a return of Josh broland
or Emily Blunt is not confirmed yet
since the film is in an early stage of
its development we expect more
announcements about the story and cast
of sakario 3
soon
despite the strike the Game of Thrones
spin-off House of the Dragon will return
in summer of 2024 with season 2 it'll
feature an ancestor of Ned Stark who
might be played by an actor of the last
Kingdom the prequel House of the Dragon
had the great Fortune of not being
affected by the writer and actor strike
the scripts had already been completed
and the actor's contracts were already
running through English trade unions
therefore the team was able to work on
the followup of the fantasy series in
peace while half of Hollywood was in
chaos House of the Dragon season 2 2
makes up for something that has been
sorely missed so far how Stark finally
plays a bigger role as it did in the
book specifically it's about the ruler
of the north krian Stark son of ricken
according to inside rumors he will be
embodied by a very specific actor the
last Kingdom actor Tom Taylor is
supposed to be the one to play him but
an official confirmation from HBO is
still not out yet we are curious to see
whether the resumption of the spin-off
series can maintain the high level as
the later seasons of the parent Series
Game of Thrones were hardly vincing
House of the Dragon season 3 has not
been commissioned by HBO yet they are
probably cautious and want to find out
about the potential of further sequels
first one of the greatest Mysteries is
getting its own feature film The Amazing
Spider-Man director Mark Webb is
devoting himself to the Bermuda Triangle
The Adventure film Bermuda will be about
the Devil's Triangle which is feared by
Sailors and where ships and aircraft
mysteriously disappear from time to time
the project has been in development for
ages and was going to be directed by a
WI wide variety of directors originally
a darker version was planned and horror
experts like Sam Ry and Scott derkson
were supposed to be responsible however
it didn't work out and that's why the
film Project disappeared from the scene
a few years ago with the casting of Mark
web however the project seems to be
coming back to life and the story of the
Bermuda Triangle is going to be made
into a big Blockbuster movie since the
film is currently still in a very early
phase of development not too much is
known about the script and a possible
cast we remain
curious after an ex exhausting 146 day
writer strike that royed the
entertainment industry there is a
glimpse of Hope The Writers Guild of
America wga and the alliance of motion
picture and television producers amtp
have reached a temporary agreement on a
new contract the news brought a
collective sigh of relief to writers
Studios and streamers and signifies a
possible end to one of the longest
strikes in wga history the announcement
came after several intense days of
negotiations the temporary agreement is
a three-year deal that still needs needs
to be ratified by wga members but seems
to be promising for the roughly 11,500
writers represented by the union the wga
has assured its members that this is an
exceptional agreement that will provide
significant benefits and protections for
authors across the board the road to
this tentative argument has been marked
by twists and turns negotiations stalled
in late August and both parties issued
public statements expressing frustration
however the talks resumed on September
14th and finally led to a breakthrough
last Sunday this development was greeted
with enthusiasm not only by the industry
but also by the public as the strike had
disrupted the production of numerous
popular television shows and movies the
ratification process for the agreement
is a multi-step process first the
Union's bargaining committee will vote
on the agreement followed by the votes
of the wga West executive committee and
the wga East Council vote tentatively
scheduled for Tuesday in addition there
will be a union leadership vote on
whether to end the strike at a date to
be determined pending ratification
although the agreement represents an
important step toward Wards ending the
strike and returning to normality in the
entertainment industry not everything is
cut and dried yet the wga leadership
will have to convince its members of the
benefits of the agreement in the
upcoming days pending official
confirmation of the deal in early
October the end of the writer strike
marks the continuation of pre-production
on numerous film projects that are
eagerly awaited for example the works on
James gun's Superman Legacy or Matt
Reeves the Batman 2 can now be completed
the planned Star Trek reboot the
Minecraft film with Jason Mamoa and
Pedra pass SC Fast and Furious 11 and
the game adaptation Rainbow 6 can also
now be further developed some series are
also to be continued again hits like
stranger things Wednesday the last of us
and Euphoria had to take a break until
now but will now finally resume the end
of the writer strike is a great relief
for at least part of the industry above
all however a large part of fictional
formats such as feature films and series
remain additionally Paralyzed by the
actor strike Gladiator 2 was already
halfway through shooting while Mission
Impossible 8 was only miss a few
re-shoot Beetlejuice 2 and Deadpool 3
also have to wait for production to
continue at least both parties have now
announced that they will meet again next
week for further conversations industry
insiders assume that the studios will in
the near future primarily concentrate on
continuing existing projects and L on
producing new ones for the latter there
are simply too few resources at the
moment because a lot of things that have
been left undone in recent months have
to be caught up in a very short time in
addition a logistical nightmare is
expected after the end of the actor
strike as everyone will then rush to the
available sets directors and actors at
the same time this is why a fierce
bidding war is expected in which the
richest Studios will win what's next for
actors is written in the stars the
industry had not even recovered yet from
the pandemic period until the strikes
happened now the upcoming Gap in movie
releases will not help the situation
we're curious to see what impact the
situation will end up having on the
movie landscape more movie releases on
streaming providers more low-budget
films new Cinema Concepts whatever it is
Will keep you
posted Netflix without 4K due to a
patent dispute Netflix customers could
soon be downgraded to watch an HD the
streaming provider apparently does not
have the necessary rights to use the
technology at all the specific issue is
the h265 standard the hardware
manufacturer broad cam has announced
that Netflix has violated the company's
patents to use it a restraining order
has already been obtained by the Munich
Regional Court this states that Netflix
is not allowed to continue using the
technology in Germany which so far has
mainly been used in 4k or Ultra HD
streams broadcom is also currently
taking legal action against Netflix in
the US and the Netherlands how the court
decision will actually affect customers
is currently unclear Netflix could
alternatively stream with the av1 codec
but this is not supported by all devices
if Netflix complies with the court
decision and cannot quickly switch its
streams to a different technology the 4K
option could disappear for many
customers however since this feature is
part of many subscription contracts this
is likely to to cause some trouble we
are curious to see how the situation
will develop in the upcoming days
especially because broadcom is also
pressing the issue in other countries
like the
US that's it for today check out our new
video about the upcoming animation
movies which will be absolute Cinema
highlights otherwise feel free to
comment us what you think of the latest
news what are you particularly
interested in and did we perhaps forget
any important news that you would like
to share with others we are curious make
sure you share them in the comments
until next time see you next week for
more Koch Che
[Music]
news